- Olga avait cru que c'était
un refuge. Et pour un moment,
C'est bien ce qu'a été le théâtre de Marioupol où elle a conduit son copain,
sa mère et sa grand-mère.
Il y avait des soins médicaux,
il y avait des médecins, des
gens faisaient à manger. C'était
une communauté et tout le monde
attendait pour ces corridors
humanitaires."
C'est la promesse d'une évacuation
de masse entendue à la radio qui a
poussé Olga à quitter son appartement qui avait été endommagé dans
une frappe de l'armée russe. C'était
le 4 mars. Mais les heures d'attente
se sont transformées en jours
et les jours sont devenus
des semaines.
"Je n'arrive pas à oublier.
Avec ma mère, on discute et on
se dit que personne ne peut nous
comprendre parce que tous
les jours, c'était le pire jour de
notre vie, mais pendant trois
semaines."
C'est depuis la sécurité
relative de Zaporijia qu'Olga
accepte d'offrir, à visage
couvert par crainte de représailles, l'un
des rares témoignages des survivants
de la frappe du théâtre de Marioupol.
Les autorités locales ont
avancé un bilan provisoire de
300 morts. Olga est convaincue
qu'il y en a largement plus, jusqu'à 1000.
Elle insiste : il n'y avait aucun militaire
ukrainien dans le théâtre.
"J'ai vu de mes propres yeux
que personne ne nous gardait.
Il n'y avait pas d'armes, il n'y
avait rien. Nous vivions en communauté.
Ils m'ont même donné
un travail. Au début, je
travaillais dans le dépôt.
Je distribuais des vêtements pour les enfants. Après, j'écoutais la radio et
tout le monde espérait un corridor
d'évacuation." Sur ces images aériennes
prises avant le bombardement, on voit
aussi clairement le mot "Diéti",
enfants en Russe, écrit au sol
devant et derrière l'édifice.
Tous les jours, Olga se demande si
le choix de rester à attendre une
évacuation des autorités est le bon.
Elle reste accrochée à la radio dans
l'espoir d'y entendre des informations concrètes. Mais à la place, ce sont les rumeurs
de voitures tombées en panne et de corps déchiquetés sur les routes minées qui la paralysent.
sur place. Les conditions de vie
sont abjectes.
"Pouvez-vous imaginer trois semaines
sans se laver les cheveux, sans se laver
le corps, le visage, vous ne
vous brossez pas les dents.
Pouvez-vous imaginer vivre comme ça.
Vous vivez dans un trou au sol.
Sans électricité. Les enfants, ils étaient
près de 500, dit Olga, pleurent sans
arrêt et tout le monde tombe
malade. Fièvre, diarrhée, vomissements.
Mais autour d'elle, tous
les jours, il y a plus
de monde, sur tous les étages
du théâtre. L'abri anti-bombes était pour
65 personnes. Il ne pouvait
en accueillir plus.
"C'était une petite pièce.
Il a été conçu pour
50 personnes, mais bon, en poussant
65 personnes y étaient. Après, les gens
étaient au sous-sol, vivaient dans un trou, éparpillés. Il y avait les bureaux.
Sur les trois étages, c'était bondé. Ils
vivaient comme ça, au sol, partout."
Le 16 mars derniers, quand le théâtre a été frappé, Olga était enfermée dans un petit bureau
pour écouter les informations à la radio.
"Ce n'était pas une bombe aérienne.
Autrement, on peut entendre les avions, on sent les vibrations qui font trembler
les fenêtres et on peut comprendre qu'il faut se mettre à l'abri pour sauver sa vie.
Mais il y avait un silence total. Il existe très peu d'images des instants qui ont
suivi l'explosion. Olga,
miraculeusement indemne,
a réussi à pousser la porte de son bureau pour aller sauver sa mère et sa grand-mère.
"J'ai sauvé ma mère quand le feu
a commencé. On entendait des cris
partout, les gens étaient en morceaux. Des bras arrachés ici, des jambes là,
personne n'est venu nous aidé, personne n'a éteint l'incendie. Je suis restée seule.
Je suis tombée dans la rue en criant
à l'aide. Ma mère ma dit :
"tue-moi, je ne veux plus vivre,
je ne veux plus rien" parce
qu'elle ne pouvait pas vivre
avec de telles blessures.
Ma grand-mère, elle a 86 ans. Elle a déjà
survécu à la guerre.
Elle croit que son copain est mort.
"Après l'explosion, il est resté sous les
décombres. Je voudrais vraiment retrouver le téléphone des volontaires qui peuvent
au moins aller dans les hôpitaux,
mais quand j'appelle la ligne est coupée.
Olga a dû supplier des voitures qui passaient pour conduire sa mère à l'hôpital
alors que les tirs pleuvaient tout près.
Sa mère a reçu des anti-douleurs, alors
que les médecins contemplaient l'amputation. Puis le lendemain, les soldats russes sont débarqués.
"Un soldat russe est arrivé, il a
dégoupillée une grenade en
disant que si on ne le traitait pas, il ferait
sauter tout le monde. J'avais terriblement
peur. Et puis, des chars sont
arrivés, beaucoup de soldats sont
arrivés. Olga a réussi à obtenir le
transfert de sa mère dans un
autre hôpital avec la promesse de soins
plus adaptés. Quand nous sommes arrivés à l'hôpital, il y avait
300 soldats russes et nous avons été
faits prisonnière. Il y avait la
faim, des gens mouraient de faim. Ils
ne donnaient que 50 grammes d'eau par personne, tout le monde volait tout
le monde et l'infection s'est répandue sur trois étages." Finalement, Olga a pu
soudoyer ceux qui les retenaient captives, elle et sa famille et appeler
des amis à l'aide. Mais faute de place dans la voiture, sa grand-mère, elle, a été
laissée derrière. Olga est aujourd'hui
rongée par des questions qui
restent sans réponse. "Tous les soirs nous faisions une prière parce qu'on
pensait que Dieu allait nous sauver.
Mais personne n'est venu nous sauver. Je ne sais pas pourquoi
et je pense que je vais mourir
avec cette question. Pourquoi?"
Elle en veut à son gouvernement
de les avoir laissés-pour-compte.
Elle en veut au reste du monde de ne pas avoir agi pour les sauver. À
Vladimir Poutine, elle réserve toute sa
haine.
Je le tuerais si j'avais la chance parce que c'est un monstre.
Ce n'est pas une personne.
Je ne sais pas comment
un homme avec des problèmes dans
sa tête peut contrôler un pays.
Je ne sais pas comment la communauté internationale peut regarder en silence.
Le plus difficile, dit la jeune femme, c'est qu'elle n'arrive pas non plus à se pardonner elle-même.
Je me sens complètement vide, je pense que je n'ai plus d'âme. Je prends des
médicaments parce que
les médecins disent que j'ai besoin d'aide. Je suis une survivante
et je me blâme tous les jours parce que c'est moi qui ai mené ma famille au théâtre.
Olga a l'impression que ce n'est pas elle
qui est assise dans cet hôpital pour raconter,
pour témoigner de ce qui s'est passé. Tout ce qu'elle était avant la guerre a été anéanti.
La positive, la patriote et la bienveillante Olga est morte, elle aussi, à Marioupol.